hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding hopefully make math a lot
less stressful so in this video what
we're gonna do I like to get right right
down to it is talking about how to
multiply monomials so what's a monomial
well monomial is like one group okay
like one term and the terms are
separated by like addition or
subtraction it separates the groups okay
so mono is like one but when you
multiply a monomial times a monomial you
want to remember how to work with the
rules of exponents okay because you're
gonna be using the distributive property
as well as the rules of exponents in
these problems so let me show you these
examples I hope this makes it easier for
you we're gonna do is you're gonna
multiply the like terms so you're
multiplying the numbers times the
numbers in the variables times the
variables so three times five gives us
15 x squared times X cubed gives us X to
the fifth because remember when you
multiply what do you do to the exponents
you add them right okay so that was kind
of an easy example let's go to a more
challenging one this one you can see you
have a monomial times a trinomial
now you probably learn the distributive
property before but just to refresh
you're gonna take this term and you're
gonna distribute it to each of the terms
okay inside of the parentheses so you're
taking this whole quantity and you're
multiplying it into the parentheses
there's nothing in between to the two X
cubed and that parentheses they're right
next to each other side by side so that
means that they're multiplied right so
what we do is we're going to distribute
two times four gives you 8x cubed times
x squared gives you X to the fifth
because remember when you multiply you
add right now when we take two x cubed
times two X we've got two times two
which is four X cubed times X to the
first remember if there's not an
exponent it's one so three plus one is
four and then two X cubed times one of
course anything times one is itself so
that's just going to give you two X
cubed now you can see if there's
anything you can combine like like terms
but you can see these are all different
x to the fifth X to the fourth X cubed
okay last example if you're enjoying
these videos go ahead and subscribe to
the channel I've got more videos like
these coming and you can check
some of my past videos but let's talk
about this last example here we've got
more than one variable we have X's and
Y's but it's the same concept you want
to take that monomial that one group
distribute it into the parentheses okay
and you want to multiply numbers times
numbers X's times X is Y's times y is
right so five times three gives you 15 x
squared times X to the first you don't
see the one where there's a 1 there so
that's X cubed Y see that's y to the
first Y square that gives you Y cubed
okay next one we're going to distribute
to here we've got 5 times negative 2
which is negative 10 x squared times X
gives you X cubed Y times y is y squared
right because you have one Y and one Y
you add those together the exponents
when you multiply this one you've got 5
times 4 which is 20 right and the x
squared and Y come along with it okay x
squared Y okay so that's our final
example again I hope you're enjoying
these videos subscribe to the channel
check out some of my past videos in the
next video I'll have a link over here up
to talk about how to do foiling and
multiplying binomials x binomials so
I'll see you in the next video